so we literally sacked one of everything
except for our queen
but we're going to sack our queen later
so far it's been rook
knight bishop and pawn
i might put this on youtube
i might just put this uh like
discovering
i mean discovering gambit where we we
literally sack
one of every piece lucini gambit
i know people are are very thirsty for
maybe lesser known newer opening traps
given that everyone's learning the
staffer these days
opinion on lucini gambit
never heard of that but i'll google it
oh
lucini gambit so f5
oh i don't think i've seen this one
so it's very specifically after d3 f5
let's go back
so i've seen there's another gambit
where black plays f5 here
there's also you can play f5 against a
spanish this is actually respectable
this is a schliemann
i went through a phase of playing this
as black
in tournament play so
i know f5 here is dubious because of d4
and sawfish likes white but bishop
okay so bishop c5 yeah i'll say i've
never
looked at the specific position it looks
interesting
it's like a a reverse vienna declined
like white's committed to this i have a
feeling it's probably dubious
we can just turn on sockfish and see if
there's any clear refutation
oh knight g5
like g5 plus three is is not a good sign
and i think it's a pretty like it's a
pretty straightforward move too
we want to play knight h6 but then
there's queen h5 and
things are really bad
oh so gmd illusion giving along knight
g5 f4
knight f7 oh interesting queen h4
wow
if if this is only plus one and g3 is
the only move
like we need two likes there's some
other at least queen e2 and queen f3
oh but then there's knight yeah knight
d4 is nice
wow discovering a new opening here
i'm intrigued i'm very intrigued
so most people castle
wow oh yeah castling is probably the
most natural
which has a bad score and computers says
it's just better for black
oh so if castling we have this move
and if takes we um this is very
reminiscent
of stafford gambit and now it's minus
five
that's so nice
yeah i think there's a there's probably
a similar line in the the vienna
i vaguely remember levy showing it it's
probably in levi's
like e4 chorus this is really cool
so this is called lucini let's make a
new study
hand it and then
flip
so it's really it's it's a very specific
position though
with d3 yeah because most people play c3
or castle but d3 is still
still if you play this as black and you
want to have some fun this might be
worth learning so the main track we just
saw is this this this
this this and black's winning
and then if g3
might require some further investigation
so it's
it's i think important to note that the
computer initially evaluates it as
like much better for white because it
sees whites winning a rook
but then doesn't think deep enough to
realize the knight's not useful on h8
so it's arriving at kind of a only
slightly better for white
which is a good sign for black
especially given blacks losing a rook
here
so generally like when i'm doing
preparation into openings i haven't seen
before i'll just
i'll have the most popular move played
be the main line
uh rather than the engine line this
looks really fun d5
what a move is an anagram of four map
bad gifts
wow i think you're right
format bad gifts
great analysis bits oh thanks thanks
holy grove
look at this move d5 out of nowhere so
black just stacked to rook and now is
sacking a pawn
but to accelerate accelerate control
over the light squares
so apparently e takes d5 is the only
non-losing move
which has never been played before only
three games with bishop takes d5
no games in the masters database
actually let's check master's database
for this position
[Music]
wow i'm actually
yeah it's actually kind of surprising
that no no one has actually tried this
in maybe serious over the board play
because it seems so easy for white to
fall into this
so let's see how bishop takes d5 loses
oh it's pronounced lucini oh like
fiancado
people were insulting my pronunciation
of fiance the other day
i could check this in chess space too
gambit is an anagram for gambit
that's brilliant very brilliant
okay so why is this losing for
so why is bishop takes d5 losing we got
to this position let's make this a main
line bishop g4
stockfish giving queen james g4 is the
best move
but what if
okay queen d2 knight d4
wow yeah this is smashing
i don't think we need to look further
like there's no way white can stop
knight f3
queen g2 also coming like all these
pieces are just doing so much damage
and white's pieces are just not doing
anything
especially this night
that's awesome okay so this is winning
for black
okay so let's look at this sign because
this is very similar where we still play
knight t4 we're threatening this
um well this position has never been
reached
spotfish giving one non-losing move for
white which is c3
hitting the knight and after this
wow it's just saying the position is a
draw after queen a4
bishop d7 and then
can repeat like bishop g7
queen d1 bishop here that's so
anti-climactic
why is c3 the only move probably to
prepare this
otherwise yeah to explain this in like
human terms
um when we play knight d4 the thread is
bishop here
and then knight f3 so c3 does two things
it it gives the queen one extra square
and it attacks the knight
so when when we play bishop g4
um the queen develops with check and
black's not actually having time to get
this move in
and if we do something else i assume the
knight's hanging
but it's still interesting so stockfish
also suggesting king f8
stacking the knights keep in mind we've
already stacked the rook
and the d-pawn now we're stacking a
knight
in this position
white still has all the pieces that
white started with
white has all eight pawns
all the minor pieces all the rooks
but black's better black's better after
fg3
taking the first pawn of the game this
is actually bananas
i had to throw out the banana from
earlier
from the thumbnail it was so bruised
it'll be remembered though
so we don't even take this we take on g3
what is this
that's crazy f takes g3
wait stockfish very confused
that's so amazing it was giving it
almost gave like plus six for white
but now it's giving black is winning
somehow
but how okay so the h pawns pinned
the bishop's hanging
so white's best move is to take the
bishop okay
so black has sacked a rook the knight
and then the bishop
and only won a pawn so far
oh but white's winning
but it's complicated okay so g takes f2
and sawfish is so confused here king d2
and now queen g2 so the issue why like
stockfish is fluctuating because
at low depth it just counts material it
sees whites up
all these pieces but then realizes that
concretely like box threats are very
strong
i could open up chest space and we can
check with a slightly stronger engine
but i think this is this is good enough
to like get us through the line
as long as we keep going
and sometimes this is what you have to
do when working with an engine like you
have to guide it through
like playing the best moves
um so here okay we're threatening to
queen with discover
check so king c3 is really the best try
then we take the rook and again we're
threatening to queen with running the
bishop will only move
yeah it seems like an only move
variation knight d2
like so far the last maybe five moves
have been only moves for each side
now we play queen e1 this is so insane
thanks so much gmd illusion for
exposing this variation
like this is just hidden beauty
it's so crazy so we we pin the knight
and the knights pin from behind
and the problem is if the king so the
king can't access these squares because
bishop d1
invading white's first race from india
your streams are top quality eric
oh thanks so much amman mitchell 13.
appreciate that
no now now like after seeing this
analysis i'm dreaming of playing this in
the game
like this is so cool so we're
threatening to queen
the knights pinned the king can't move
here here moves here it's still pinned
and our our um clutch e5 pawn
preventing king d4
so the best try for white according to
the engine
oh is um yeah there's d4 to control f1
let's look at d4 first man it's just
like a
a mesh of pieces just a cluster
white has no harmony like among these
pieces and just a knight randomly on h8
so we play queen e3
bishop d3 king b4 is a funny like king
b4
here king b5 we take
a bishop d7 incoming
bishop d7 here this is some some mating
idea
i'm black's fighting made in two
so best try is bishop d3
oh but bishop d3
i like this move e4 e4 is so nice
because the bishop's pinned and the
knight is tied down to guarding f1
if knight takes him we queen because the
bishop still pinned
oh but we can't do that because our
queen's hanging wait
whoa we sack a queen
only winning move for black is to sack
the queen here
and then the queen is reborn
just to keep initiative
how many pieces has black sacked in this
line
wait slow motion replay okay
we we need to internalize what just
happened
so is very deep theory we start with f5
we we bait white or maybe debate white
into playing knight g5 we're we're
threatening this uh
this fork it looks really good for white
but then f4
knight f7 queen h4 so threatening maiden
one
um g3
okay so the first sacrifice is a rook so
we're down a rook
and then d5 sacking
a pawn so we're down they're rooking
upon
and we play bishop g4 we play king f8
another sacrifice we're down a night
rook and pawn
okay we win back something but then we
sack a bishop
so we literally sacked one of everything
except except for our queen
but we're going to sack our queen later
so far it's been rook
knight bishop and pawn
and then if we go forward with this main
line okay we went back to rook
and then so after e4 in this position
we sack our queen to promote the pawn
and then it's winning somehow i think
we're just
we're just winning everything and the
queen is useless
and so is the rest of the pieces uh king
we can analyze king c3 queen f3
d2 so king d2 we don't even take the
knight we play rook e8
which is winning there's just too much
too many mating threats
and then if king c4 then we take the
knight and
um did we win back all the material
so we we get to a position where only
down a pawn
but white's king is on c4 there's bishop
e2 ideas
and white's just dead and the knight
stuck knight f6 coming
wow okay um
i mean there's definitely more to
analyze in this line
but this this main line that we have is
just
it's simply incredible and um
i might put this on youtube
i might just put this uh like
discovering
i mean discovering a gambit where we
literally sack
one of every piece lucini gambit
i'll have to do more analysis if you're
watching in the future on youtube
i'll link the study i'll probably like
by the time i post this video i'll have
more
more analysis but it's such a cool
gambit
um there might be other lines where
white's actually better but
keep in mind like the top stockfish move
okay now it's not even recommending that
knight g5 it was recommending knight g5
earlier
um it's a very human move too
and played 233 times
so okay i hope maybe some people can
find value
value in this maybe play it in their own
games see how it goes